hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcasts and keynote presentation
a regulatory perspective on molecular
diagnostic devices presented by dr.
Eunice Lee chief of the molecular
pathology and cytology branch in the
office of in vitro diagnostics and
radiological health at the US Food and
Drug Administration
my name is Gary Stein and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots lab
roots is the leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box that appears on the
screen dr. Lee will be responding to
your questions via email if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the promotional
board at the bottom slash center of your
screen or use the ask a question box to
let us know that you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
July of 2018 so please join me in
welcoming dr. Eunice Lee I will now turn
the presentation over to her
thank you very much for that
introduction Gary and I'd like to extend
a thank you to the organizers of this
event as mentioned my group is the
molecular pathology and cytology branch
and it's within the division of
molecular genetics and pathology at the
FDA we review a variety of invitro
diagnostic devices ranging from whole
slide imaging systems to
immunohistochemistry tests or IHC tests
and nucleic acid-based tests for some
oncology indications so today I'll
provide a regulatory perspective on
molecular diagnostic devices with
particular focus on companion
diagnostics and next-generation
sequencing based on ecology panels
before I begin I would just like to note
that the information presented today are
only intended for summary and discussion
purposes if there are specific questions
about any of the examples that I talked
about today about the specific devices
please refer to the decision summaries
and the summaries of safety and
effectiveness data or SS EDS
which are publicly available documents
on the FDA website and at the last slide
I'll have some a link to the medical
device database where this information
can be accessed today I'll start by
providing an overview of the regulation
of in vitro diagnostic devices or IV DS
then I'll touch on some assay
performance considerations and discuss
how we evaluate IV D products then I'll
move to companion diagnostics providing
an overview and discussing some key
issues in Co development and then I'll
move beyond companion diagnostics and
briefly talk about follow-on companion
diagnostics and complementary
diagnostics and then I'll end by
discussing NGS or next-generation
sequencing oncology panels I'll talk
about the validation considerations for
these types of
tests and also provide some examples of
recent FDA authorizations that have
significantly impacted the current
regulatory paradigm for these types of
devices so what is an IV D in the Code
of Federal Regulations or the CFR which
is basically the set of rules and
regulations by which we abide an IV D is
defined as reagents instruments and
systems intended for use in diagnosis of
disease or other conditions including a
determination of the state of health in
order to cure mitigate treat or prevent
disease or it's equally such products
are intended for use in the collection
preparation and examination of specimens
taken from the human body and this
definition can be found in 21 CFR part
eight oh nine point three when the
agency reviews an IV D we rely on valid
scientific evidence in order to provide
reasonable assurance that the device is
safe and effective for its intended use
so with regard to safety the central
question is really are there reasonable
assurances based on valid scientific
evidence that the probable benefits to
health from use of the device will
outweigh any probable risks with regard
to effectiveness similar question is are
there reasonable assurances again based
on valid scientific evidence that the
use of the device in the target
population will provide clinically
significant results so within the
regulatory framework when evaluating the
safety and effectiveness of the devices
the devices are actually classified
based on a risk based classification
system so there are three regulatory
classes for devices class 1 class 2 and
class 3 and there are differing levels
of controls for each of these classes
where the current level of control will
increase from class 1 to class 3
class 1 devices are considered to be low
risk these devices are subject to
general controls class two devices are
moderate risk and they are subject to
both general controls as well as special
controls and class 3 devices are the
highest risk category and for these both
general and special controls alone are
not sufficient to mitigate the risks
that are associated with the devices for
their intended uses so the risk
classification is wholly dependent upon
the intended use of the device and this
is basically the manner in which the
device is intended to be used so the
intended use is a statement that will
specify the analytes that are being
measured the specimen type that's being
tested as well as providing the context
in which the device should be used so
for example if there's a clinical claim
for prognosis or diagnosis or monitoring
that will be included in the intended
use statement as mentioned this is a
risk based classification and so for IV
DS it's really the risk that is
associated with obtaining false results
from that test and it's the level of
risk that is posed to the patients and
the users of that device the
classification is not based on
technology so even if you have a very
complex technological assay this alone
will not automatically place the device
in the high-risk category however the
technology or the methodology will
influence the types of validation
studies that will be needed to
demonstrate the safety and effectiveness
of the product
so within the regulatory framework the
classification of the device will
determine the pre-market regulatory
pathway for that device although all
devices are subject to be labeled
properly to be manufactured under a
quality assurance program and to have
establishment registration and device
listing forms on file with the FDA but
each class here has a different
regulatory path for example most class 1
low-risk devices are exempt from
premarket notification that is a 510 K
application is not required for those
devices however as I mentioned those
class 1 devices are still subject to
registration and listing class 2 devices
most of them will require a 510 K
submission in order to obtain FDA
clearance and they obtain clearance by
demonstrating that the device is
substantially equivalent to a legally
marketed predicate device in some cases
the class 2 devices may be exempt from
premarket notification and in other
cases there may be an absence of a
predicate device where that device type
has not previously been classified and
in that case then a de novo request for
classification can be submitted for that
device and once authorized that device
can then serve as a predicate for
subsequent devices of the same device
type and then for class 3 high-risk
devices these are subject to a PMA
application to be submitted for FDA
approval so what do we look at when we
review of these medical devices listed
here are the elements of FDA review the
intended use
the indications for use as discussed in
the previous slide are very central to
our review we also look at the
performance of the device which is
comprised of the analytical validation
and the clinical validation when
applicable the instrument and the
software validation is also reviewed we
also look at the labeling and the
labeling for the device must be
compliant with CFR eight or nine point
ten and as I mentioned previously all
devices must be manufactured under a
quality assurance program and they must
meet the quality system regulation
however for PMA applications the quality
system regulation information is
reviewed in the pre market setting so
I'll delve a little bit further into the
scientific review as I mentioned this is
comprised of both the analytical and the
clinical performance the analytical
performance should really demonstrate
the reliability and the accuracy of the
analyte measurements detected by that
test the studies can be specific to that
assay methodology as well as the
intended use and an example of this is
for IHC or immunohistochemistry assays
reader studies are needed
however from molecular nucleic
acid-based tests reader studies aren't
needed but accuracy studies are required
with regard to clinical performance the
test should be correlated with a
clinically meaningful and clinically
significant outcome and some measures to
demonstrate this can be clinical
sensitivity and specificity or positive
and negative predictive values as
appropriate for a few considerations for
analytical performance the test is
really considered as the whole system so
the validation should encompass all the
way from specimen collection and
preparation all the way through to
result reporting and therefore this
includes the pre and a little
steps the validation studies should also
be conducted with the intended specimen
type by using clinical specimens from
the intended population it's also
important to evaluate the performance of
the device across the entire reportable
and measuring range for that device and
this includes around the clinical
cut-offs and importantly the studies
should follow the protocol that will be
in the final device labeling for
clinical performance it should be
determined how the device will be used
in the clinical setting and then the
study design should ensure that it is
appropriate in order to support the
intended use of the device the clinical
study as well as the statistical
analysis plan should be pre specified
and clinical performance should be
established by comparing to an endpoint
or an appropriate surrogate and
typically analytical validation will
precede clinical validation now we'll
move on to companion diagnostics
companion diagnostics are a subset of IV
DS the definition of a companion
diagnostic is that it's a test that
provides information that is essential
for the safe and effective use of a
corresponding therapeutic because the
use of the companion diagnostic and the
corresponding therapeutic are
interdependent the use of the companion
along with the drug is specified in the
labeling of both the diagnostic as well
as the corresponding therapeutic it's
expected that there is contemporaneous
regulatory approvals for both the device
and the corresponding therapeutic
therefore when we review an IV D
application for a companion diagnostic
the review timeline is tied to the
corresponding application for the
therapeutic
product there are however exceptions
when contemporary knees approval may not
be possible and this may happen if there
is an unmet need or if it's in the best
interest of Public Health to approve a
drug prior to approval of the device in
such cases then the companion diagnostic
approval will be included as a post
marketing commitment on the therapeutic
side so for more information about FDA
expectations for companion diagnostics
you can refer to the final draft
guidance which is titled in-vitro
companion diagnostic devices the final
guidance was issued in August of 2014 in
there the definition of a companion is
provided and various scenarios for use
are described in addition FDA policies
for approval and labeling are outlined
to date there are more than 40 approved
companion diagnostic and therapeutic
combinations all of them except for one
are for oncology indications for 18
approved cancer therapeutics there are
33 approved unique IVD companion
diagnostics and all of them except for
one went through the PMA pathway and
these tests cover a total of 18
different biomarkers for a complete and
up-to-date listing of the cleared and
approved companion diagnostic devices
you can refer to the website shown on
this slide so as I mentioned the use of
a device
the use of a companion diagnostic is
tied to the use of a corresponding
therapeutic product and so there are
several key questions that will arise
regarding Co development first how do
you know that a companion diagnostic
device is needed second when you use a
test to identify a biomarker in
the clinical trial for the therapeutic
product will an investigational device
exemption or IDE application be needed
and third what if the final device was
not used in the therapeutic clinical
trial and finally how can a test receive
the same companion diagnostic claim as
the originally approved companion
diagnostic so I'll answer each one of
these questions in the subsequent slides
so first about the need for a companion
diagnostic typically both the
therapeutic and the device are studied
in the same clinical trial
therefore the clinical validation of the
device is supported by the results of
the therapeutic trial in other words the
results from the primary efficacy
population that are used to support
approval of the drug that is the
population that will also be used to
support device approval so when you use
a device in a clinical trial it's very
important that that assay is fully
specified and is locked down prior to
its use in that trial and what I mean by
that is that a specific assays should be
identified for detecting the marker in
that trial the specific protocol should
be identified and the clinical decision
points that will be used to define
biomarker positivity versus biomarker
negativity should be specified in
addition the specific specimen type
should be identified it's also important
that the assay is adequately validated
prior to its use in the trial so
ultimately the decision about the need
for a companion diagnostic is made by
the therapeutic review division but they
make this decision in consultation with
the device center so for these companion
diagnostics they really take a great
deal of collaboration and coordination
between the respective review centers as
well as between the respective device
and drug sponsors
so when thinking about whether companion
diagnostic is needed the central
questions are really is there adequate
evidence of clinical activity of the
therapeutic in the biomarker selected
population as identified by the
companion diagnostic and most
importantly is the test essential for
the safe and effective use of the
corresponding therapeutic product if the
answer to this is yes then undoubtedly
a companion diagnostic will be needed so
what about the need for an IDE
application an approved IDE permits the
device to be shipped lawfully in order
to conduct investigations of the device
without complying with other
requirements of the Food Drug and
Cosmetic Act that would apply to devices
in commercial distribution so typically
when a device is used in a clinical
trial its be it has not been approved
for that indication to be legally
marketed and so an IDE provides for an
exemption for use of that device and the
trial so when we look at all device
investigations some of them may be
subject to the IDE regulation while
others may be exempt from the IDE
regulation of those that are subject to
the IDE regulation some are considered
to be significant risk and therefore
subject to the full IDE requirements
while others may be non significant risk
and although an IDE application does not
need to be submitted to the agency for
these NSR studies they are subject to
the abbreviated IDE requirements which
can be found in 21 CFR part 812 so the
determination about the need for an IDE
is not a benefit risk decision it's
really an assessment of risk that is
posed to the patients who are enrolled
into that trial so the question is does
use of the test result pose a
significant risk if the answer is yes
and most likely that trial will be
use of the device in that trial will be
considered to be significant risk and an
IDE application will be needed in order
to determine if an IDE is needed for a
specific trial we recommend that a study
risk determination pre submission is
submitted to the Center for Devices so
the third question was about what
happens if the clinical trial assay or
CTA differs from the companion
diagnostic so one example of when this
might happen is if a prototype of an
assay is used to enroll patients in the
trial and then the assay goes through
some optimization or some changes and
then a different assay will come forward
for marketing authorization in such a
case changing the test can lead to
changes in the assay performance and
this in turn can change the patient
population from what was selected in the
therapeutic clinical trial when this
happens
bridging studies are required in order
to perform a bridging study patient
specimens that tested both CTA negative
and CTA positive should be retained and
banked so that they can be retested with
the final companion diagnostic device in
such a case there should be no
collection or selection bias and
therefore you should ensure that the
samples that are stored there and their
integrity is maintained and one way to
do this is through demonstration of the
stability of the analytes in those
stored specimens in order to ensure that
the storage duration was acceptable and
the quality of the assay is acceptable
when performing bridging study
statistical analysis plan should
consider potential discordance 'as and
also should account for any missing
samples importantly bridging studies are
not just a method comparison study
bridging studies should evaluate the
concordance between the CTA test results
and the companion diagnostic test
results but it should also demonstrate
that the clinical outcomes that were
correlated with the CTA are maintained
with the test results from the companion
diagnostic device the last question was
about the possibility for the same
companion diagnostic claim as the
original companion diagnostic claim for
a new test it's recognized that often
times samples from the original clinical
trial that's used to support the
approval of the original companion
diagnostic may not exist any longer or
they just may not be available for
retesting in such a case there are two
potential pathways that could be
followed in order to gain the same
companion diagnostic claim the first is
that they can follow the path of the
original companion diagnostic they could
perform a new clinical trial in order to
obtain clinical outcome data that's
correlated with the new test we
recognize that it can be extremely
burdensome and costly to perform a new
clinical trial and so an alternative
path is to get a follow-on companion
diagnostic claim a follow-on companion
diagnostic should consistently and
accurately select the same intended use
patient population as the originally
approved companion diagnostic device and
therefore the can follow on companion
diagnostic should demonstrate the same
or the comparable level of analytical
and clinical performance for the
specific mutations or the specific
analytes that are being tested in the
originally approved companion diagnostic
so in order to demonstrate this
performance it's important that a
clinical concordance study which is
essentially a method comparison
study is performed to compare the new
test with the previously approved
companion diagnostic so a term that has
emerged in the recent past is
complementary Diagnostics and these are
tests that in contrast to companion
diagnostics these are not essential for
the safe and effective use of the
therapeutic product complementary
Diagnostics identify a biomarker to find
subsets of patients who respond
particularly well to a drug and aid in
the benefit risk assessment for
individual patients therefore it is not
a prerequisite for receiving the drug an
example of a situation in which a
complementary diagnostic would arise is
when a drug is approved for an
all-comers however there may be
differential clinical outcomes based on
biomarker status as defined by this
complementary diagnostic and so in such
cases then a complementary diagnostic
may be needed because the complementary
Diagnostics are also studied in the
clinical trial that's used to evaluate
the performance of the therapeutic
product the development path for
complementary Diagnostics is similar to
that for companion diagnostics so now
I'll move on to NGS oncology panels
these next-generation sequencing based
on ecology panels are increasingly being
employed in the clinical setting part of
their advantage is that they have the
ability to screen a very large number of
biomarkers which can be up to thousands
of biomarkers that can be screened
simultaneously therefore the tests
have broad intended uses due to the
sheer volume of the number of sequences
that can be obtained from a single run
validation for such a test on a per
variant or per market basis is not
feasible and therefore these types of
tests have introduced challenges to the
companion diagnostic paradigm which
traditionally has been one test for one
drug as I mentioned previously the
validation studies for a device should
be designed to support the performance
characteristics of that device for its
intended use but as I mentioned there
are challenges one is that it is not
feasible to validate all possible
alterations that may be detected by an
NGS test a second clinical specimens for
analytical validation may be limiting
particularly for rare tumor types or for
tumors in which there are low prevalence
biomarkers and third there is a lack of
reference methods and standards that can
be used in order to demonstrate the
accuracy of these NGS uncle panels so in
the next few slides I'll address each of
these challenges by presenting
strategies that have been implemented by
some of the tests that we've reviewed
first with regard to the inability to
evaluate every single variant that could
be detected by an NGS test it's
recognized that this is terribly
burdensome and therefore we recommend
that all variants with clinical
companion diagnostic claims should be
included in the validation studies
however these NGS tests include can
include many more genes or biomarkers
that extend beyond the markers so
with a companion diagnostic claim so in
such cases we then recommend that a
representative approach can be taken in
order to support the validation of those
other single nucleotide variants and
insertions and deletions or in Dells
when taking a representative approach
it's important that a range of variant
types are included which represent or
give consideration to the sizes of the
different variants as well as the
contexts the genomic context that those
variants can be detected in on the other
hand a representative variant approach
is not acceptable for fusions or gene
rearrangements because the performance
of the device for one gene fusion may
not be able to be extrapolated to
fusions detected in other genes so what
I really mean by this is that if fusions
in the AL gene are used in the
validation studies this cannot be used
in order to gain claims that the test
can detect fusions in other genes such
as rosslyn however within the AL gene we
recommend that the most common the two
or three most common out confusions are
represented in the validation studies in
order to obtain the claim that a test
can detect alkanes and so therefore
every single out fusion that has been
identified does not need to be included
in the validation studies there are also
can be some post-market considerations
in order to obtain a pre market post
market balance and so there may be
circumstances under which post market
data can be provided for some analytical
studies in order to further demonstrate
the performance of the device
regarding the potential lack of clinical
specimens the test performance should be
established with the intended clinical
specimens however in certain analytical
studies it may be appropriate to use
contrived samples provided at an
appropriately designed functional
characterization study is performed so a
contrived sample functional
characterization study basically should
demonstrate that the contrived samples
are able to appropriately mimic the
clinical specimens and therefore can be
used as surrogates in the validation
studies another consideration for pan
tumor claims in which it is not possible
to test every single tumor type that has
been identified in these cases we
recommend that comparability across a
variety of common and challenging tumors
is demonstrated and we typically
recommend that at least 10 tumor types
are represented also because different
tumor types can have different potential
interference it's important to assess
interference effects
an example is melanin in melanoma and
then finally we also recommend that data
is provided regarding the invalid rates
and the performance metrics across tumor
types and this information can be based
on historical data or a retrospective
analysis of data that already exists
regarding the lack of reference methods
in order to demonstrate accuracy a
validated orthogonal method may be used
as a comparator if the method is not an
fda-approved
or an FDA cleared test then minimal
level of validation data is needed for
the comparator and we generally
recommend that at a minimum limit of
and sensitivity studies as well as DNA
input and precision studies are
performed to support the performance of
that other test as a comparator method
to demonstrate accuracy of the test
additional validation considerations are
that the validation should evaluate how
different source errors can affect
device performance
NGS tests are a complex process that
involves numerous steps in the workflow
this encompasses sample preparation
library construction sequencing and data
analysis and even result reporting in
such cases for these types of tests
different error profiles are associated
with different analytes which can range
from parameters including variant type
genomic context and allele frequency so
therefore we recommend that quality
metrics are established at both the
sample and the variant levels and that
these quality metrics should really look
beyond exon level coverage and so some
of the quality metrics that we request
are listed here the reportable range
should be clearly defined and this is
with respect to genomic regions variant
types that will be detected by the assay
as well as the variant allele
frequencies that are detected and all of
the quality control metrics and the
validations should be developed in order
to ensure the performance of the device
within the claimed reportable range in
addition sequencing metrics should be
provided such as the run in the sample
QC mapping metrics which will include
coverage and coverage should cover depth
completeness and uniformity and
additional metrics can be variant
calling as well as reporting metrics so
the validation considerations that I
discussed were implemented
and stemmed from our experiences with
NGS tests that we've reviewed so listed
here are some of the NGS tests actually
all of the NGS tests that we have
reviewed and cleared or approved the
first NGS tests were actually not
companion diagnostic devices those were
approved in November of 2013 and those
were two Illumina tests that were
intended to detect cystic fibrosis
variants that are intended to aid in the
diagnosis of cystic fibrosis as they're
not companion diagnostics and they were
for an aid and diagnosis for cystic
fibrosis those went through the 510 k
pathway the first NGS based companion
diagnostic test was approved in December
of 2016 and that was the foundation
focus CDX bracha test from from
foundation medicine that tests detected
variance in the Braco one and the
bracket two genes and more recently in
June and November of last year for
next-generation sequencing tests were
approved three of these were considered
next-generation sequencing oncology
panels and they're listed here so
basically these tests included genes
beyond those that have companion
diagnostic claims so the first test that
was approved in June of 2017 went
through the PMA pathway and it was for
the angka mine DX target test from
thermo Fisher Scientific the next was
approved in note was cleared in November
of 2017 and that was for the msk impact
test from Memorial sloan-kettering and
this went through the Genova pathway and
therefore it did not have any specific
companion diagnostic claims associated
with it and then finally later in that
same month on November 30th the
foundation 1c DX test was approved the
p.m. a pathway and that test is from
Foundation medicine so these three FDA
authorizations have really shaped the
current regulatory paradigm for NGS
uncle panels and that's shown here so in
the classical companion diagnostic model
where it was one test for one drug
you only had biomarkers with companion
diagnostic claims but with the recent
clearance of the msk impact panel this
really created some additional levels of
biomarkers that are associated with
different levels of evidence and so you
can see that the while I'll refer to
level 1 biomarkers as those with
companion diagnostic claims level 2
biomarkers are those that are considered
to be cancer mutations with evidence of
clinical significance and level 3
biomarkers are the cancer mutations with
potential clinical significance and I'll
talk about the examples here the uncle
mine test and the foundation one CDX
tests all fit into the level 1 category
but they actually had both level 1 2 & 3
biomarkers while the msk impact test
went through a class-2 pathway and had
only level 2 and level 3 biomarkers but
it's important to note that a test
cannot be cleared with only level 3
biomarkers and so level 3 biomarkers are
obtained along with level 2 and/or level
1 biomarker claims so to talk a little
bit more about each of these three tests
the angka my index target test is a lung
cancer panel the tested text single
nucleotide variants and deletions in 23
dreams from DNA as well as fusions in
the Ross 1 gene from RNA that has been
isolated from FFPE tumor tissue samples
from non-small-cell lung cancer patients
it was the first approved test that
simultaneously assesses variants in
different genes in order to determine
patient eligibility for treatment with
multiple non-small cell lung cancer
targeted therapies and therefore it had
multiple companion diagnostic claims
which are listed here
the first is that the test was approved
to detect b-raf v600 mutations for
treatment with depravity and tremendum
it was approved for the detection of
Ross one fusions for treatment with
crizotinib and it also was approved with
a follow-up companion diagnostic claim
to detect EGFR exon 19 deletions and l85
8 our substitution mutations for
treatment which a fitting in and
therefore this test had both level 1
level 2 and level 3 claims for the msk
impact test the intended use is shown
here the assay is a qualitative in vitro
diagnostic test that uses targeted
sequencing of FFPE tumor tissue matched
with normal specimens from patients with
solid malignant neoplasms in order to
detect tumor gene alterations the test
is intended to detect mutations that
include point mutations and small indels
as well as microsatellite instability
and its intended for use by qualified
healthcare professionals in accordance
with professional guidelines importantly
the test is not conclusive or
prescriptive for labeled use of any
specific therapeutic product and
therefore it does not have the level 1
biomarker or companion diagnostic claims
the msk impact test is a solid tumor
panel it identifies mutations in 468
genes as well as microsatellite
as I mentioned this went through the de
novo pathway and it really established a
class-2 pathway for these NGS uncle
panels that have only level 2 and level
3 claims so these are considered to be
class 2 tumor profiling tests and they
are eligible for third party review
third party review is a program that was
implemented in order to approve the
efficiency and the timeliness of the
510k review process for certain device
types under this program there are
accredited third parties who can conduct
the 510k review and they will provide
the review package as well as their
recommendation to the FDA after they
have reviewed the information and so
really devices under this class can go
through the class to pathway either
through the third party review pathway
or they can directly submit a 510k
submission to the FDA and I'd also like
to note that one of the accredited third
party reviewers for this type of test is
New York State Department of Health so
going back to the regulatory paradigm we
have the three levels of review and we
saw based on the uncle mind test that it
had claims for both level for all of the
levels level 1 level 2 and level 3
importantly the validation for level 1
biomarkers which have companion
diagnostic claims require that
analytical validation is performed for
each marker associated with such a
companion diagnostic acclaim the
clinical claims are established through
a clinical study or for follow-on
companion diagnostics through clinical
concordance results
for level two claims analytical
validation can be conducted per marker
or through representative approach for
SMBs and indels in contrast to the level
one the level of evidence for clinical
validation is that it can be established
in professional guidelines but it does
not have to be demonstrated directly
with the test of interest and then for
level three biomarkers and a little cook
validation is supported through the
representative approach while clinical
validation is not demonstrated either in
professional guidelines or with the test
but rather it's suggestive based on
available evidence and that available
available evidence can include mecca's
mechanistic rationale as well as
published literature so for the last NGS
uncle panel that has recently been
approved this was the foundation once
EDX it's a solid tumor panel and the
test was approved to detect
substitutions in der indels which are
insertions and deletions as well as copy
number alterations in 324 genes as well
as select gene rearrangements it was
also approved to detect two genomic
signatures microsatellite instability
and tumor mutation burden the test was
approved for use with 15 targeted
therapies in five different cancer types
and therefore it had companion
diagnostic claims and it's also intended
to provide tumor mutation profiling in
accordance with professional guidelines
and these are level 2 biomarker claims
importantly this test was the first
breakthrough device to complete the PMA
process and it was the second device to
be reviewed and approved under the fda
CMS parallel review program here's an
excerpt a quick snapshot of the intended
use from the device shown here is table
with all of the companion diagnostic
claims for which the device is approved
you can see here the five different
tumor types are not small cell lung
cancer melanoma breast cancer colorectal
cancer and ovarian cancer along with the
associated biomarkers and therapeutics
so as I mentioned this was the second
IVD that was reviewed and approved under
the fda CMS parallel review program this
parallel review program was piloted in
2011 and fully implemented in 2016 and
it's aimed at reducing the time between
FDA approval of a device and CMS
Medicare coverage so on November 30th
when the FDA approved this device on the
same day CMS issued a proposed national
coverage determination or an NC d for
NGS cancer diagnostics for Medicare
beneficiaries after the public comment
period
CMS finalized the NCD on March 16th of
this year for NGS for Medicare
beneficiaries with advanced cancer the
coverage is for diagnostic laboratories
using NGS tests for patients with
advanced cancer and that's defined as
being recurrent metastatic
relapsed/refractory
or advanced cancer as stages 3 & 4 in
order to get coverage the test must have
FDA approval or clearance as a companion
diagnostic it also must have an
fda-approved or cleared indication for
use in the patient's cancer and the
results should be provided to the
treating physician using a report
template to specify the treatment
options the coverage decision also noted
that coverage for other NGS lab tests
for Medicare patients with cancer are
made by local Medicare administrative
ders and for more information about the
decision memorandum on CMS's NCD the
link is provided at the bottom of this
slide so in conclusion I think the
regulatory models for companion
diagnostics and NGS oncology panels have
really evolved over time due to
increasing efforts and personalized
medicine and a lot of these efforts have
really been driven by device innovation
and device advancements and a couple of
takeaways are that these type to bring
these products to market it takes a lot
of collaboration and coordination
between all of the stakeholders for
example for companion diagnostics it
takes coordination communication between
the diagnostic and the drug sponsors as
well as within the agency between the
review centers the respective review
centers also through programs like third
party review and parallel review it
takes a lot of coordination between
agencies as well as with the device
sponsors as well so with that I'd like
to end here and listed here are a few
additional resources to get some
additional information on some of the
topics that I've discussed today and
also if after this session any questions
arise about specific devices or anything
I've talked about today you can please
feel free to send me any questions at
the email address here thank you very
much